hey guys welcome to the report on Dave
Rubin classing up the joint wearing a
jacket
this week about with bites man with me
jack more with me
and here we go are you drinking alcohol
like old-school alcohol that was mixed
maybe in a distillery
or a winery or something like that that
is old school get news cool people
it's now in powdered form the alcohol
tobacco tax and trade Bureau has
approved
how cahall which is a powdered alcoholic
drink mix
for sale and distribution I am basically
it's exactly what it sounds like it's
basically Kool Aid
that you just add some water too and you
can get smashed
I believe we have a an image if sum up
the packaging
they're quitting get a pack cosmopolitan
a mojito a powder reader
which barely taste just like a margarita
and a lemon drop amongst the couple
others
and that there's been some confusion on
the internet whether this was approved
or was an approved which seems like it
up to a bit
up debate the labels I guess had been
approved yet
the but the would you drink powdered
alcohol is this the future is everything
gonna be in powdered form
I feel very conflicted because I don't
drink by love novelty items
so I like I kinda wanna have the power
out hardest because it's ridiculous and
Mike
you know it's a thing to do right would
you snort the powdered outcall
if you don't drink as a non drinker yeah
not to overthink it loophole
yes not at I like making a face mask I
love it
yes reverend your skin yeah I'll or
paste
whatever it takes whatever is among a
drink it not gonna drink it
as the jack anything that makes the
making jungle juice for college parties
easier is going to succeed
so I I can imagine I i think the prank
potential of powdered alcoholism really
high
you know just like your friends away
like it's finally a fun surprise to
leave in someone's drink you know not a
dangerous one so
you know you leave a little powder Rita
in there and
they get a nice little surprise as
they're having brunch we're going to bed
you know I can see college kids across
america it's the new
the new trend on campus yes remember a
couple was it like a year ago there was
gonna be beer that was just a vapor and
you could just get wasted like that
people always fight this stuff but you
really can't fight progress can you want
okay
if people want to have a little packet
the powdered booze they're never right
now everything will be okay
yeah of relative sprinkling alcohol on
your feet I was a flavor enhancer
or just to get drunk on fries whatever
it takes to get a margarita french fries
yet 1 I'm get drunk at the same time
that router not a terrible seem like the
future actually
yeah I'm soft I am do you think they're
gonna have
you know alternate company they're gonna
start cutting it was tough you look at
these there is a drug
element to this you know it I mean where
you gonna get the purest up
and then it's going to be cut with some
some grain or something right
gasoline gasoline whatever it is yeah
yeah it's just
I'd I mean we really have the equivalent
I'm sure these things just taste
like bad it but why mexico is basically
like that brings
the things they sell in like pouches at
you know
cies I was there all the wine cooler
brand like from the 80's those two guys
there's 20 guys
particles in vital in jail here in Table
II exactly so it's just it's
that's my one problem with is like do
you need another step towards alcohol
like has anybody ever been like man I
love drinking
but only there was another preparatory
step between me and getting drunk
right I don't think that's stopping you
it's actually better because you think
about it you know what you would have
another drink but I really wanna open
this powder packet
and mix it with water right way at that
time could it also be the river so that
like where people want to get drunk
easily let's say you're at a baseball
game and you don't want to pay
12 bucks for a beer you can go I go I
got a bottle of water
lax about what I cause a but they are
you bring your own water right and then
irian to the crystallite so financially
it makes sense
share if you were the much-ballyhooed I
just never
had like Kool Aid and thought to myself
like man I have
kool aid more like I want this to expand
into other
areas of my life and so I don't the idea
I've making alcoholic who live
doesn't exactly can you told me like hey
I made a budget alcoholic cool they
would you like some I would definitely
say no
you would not try that so is this really
though this seems to me that this is
really about kids drinking
the know that's where the you know like
taking a course there are marketed to
adult
but the people that are really gonna be
smuggling packet
the parties and to family a bed gonna be
kids so there is some risk
I wanna package like Pixie Stix we could
have a and the whole and I will open
minded
find it even better up that what you're
thinking outside the box
yet now only use it as alcoholic funded
that actually is the best
that sounds great in another way sugar
sticks and
yeah I'm in should be P be concerned
about the kids the kids
well you know it because I always think
that someone has to be heard about the
kids you no matter what you mean consent
and
luxuries like those worried about kids
it does seem a
like this will be a very shoplifted item
whether it's much easier to go into a
store in grab a little pouch of
something else
that will fit in anybody's pocket then
to like
grab a bunch of bottles them as a kid
like pocket for powder
just like grabbing and portable hardware
and walking around just like leaving a
trail of
Palka hall behind them it just has so
much better so many occasions alcohol
not good
yeah it sounds like a department of like
pals and alcohol
which already is like out now the I will
maybe the
pack a whole people have some marking
issues to work on they still gotta get
the labels approved and everything so we
will see
what happened there when it becomes
legal we will drink it here do official
taste test
all right let's talk about prop eight we
can't do one week without something gay
at this when i think is actually kinda
interesting a surcharge Cooper who is
one of the lawyers
that with poor prop a meaning he was
against
marriage equality and bought it at the
Supreme Court
we're not gonna believe this he has put
prop and that the Act
he's now for gay marriage why for his
stepdaughter
lesbian want to get married incredible
how this works out we got a quote from
general Cooper my views about on issues
at this kind the same way as other
people do
and how I view this down the road may
not be the way I do it now or how I
viewed it ten years ago that attorney
Charles Cooper
back to basically that seems good to me
he's trying to get on the right side
history except the
Supreme Court case wasn't that long ago
and is it a little disingenuous like now
it affected you
personally so you're gonna get on the
right I like this kinda
in a weird way I'm happy that happened
but it kinda seems like it
dick move activity we cancel judge him
right there until you get her a judge in
yet know when you're here this are you
okay I'm fine with that i mean good for
him
but like that very question mark yeah
like good for you that you personally
affected you and now you're deciding
that you have to not be an asshole
yet can you guys the Busby do some sorta
wanted those
what do you call on that frickin tests
the you know whether the quizzes can you
do want the quizzes
I like how you evolved on gay marriage
with all your crazy can you make it go
do that right now please after that you
make that
really I mean I took it could he did a
but like it's literally about what is it
about a year later something media
throughout with less than a year later
at like nine months later and it seems
like will it affect you personally so
now you're gonna come on board like
it I she blows my mind that there are
still people in this country
who don't see that this war has been
lost
guide them like bigots have lost this
war it's just going to happen
it's not there's no going back now and
to its it the equivalent love being
a segregationist in 1982 layer
its you it the wars done right and so
the fact with more shocking is that
there are there are so many people who
haven't evolved their stance I did
should be graciously accept this guy
should be like yeah sure you for it
you forget that less than a year ago in
the supreme court but about you have a
lesbian step daughter
welcome I mean I think good thoughts I
think it well I we are accepting but I
also think it's a great
feather in the cap because that if even
this guy I mean this is this is Darth
Vader like hanging out he walks like
it's
I its impossible to be touched by this
issue personally
and not come to the right conclusion
if Dick Cheney who I'm pretty sure is an
evil robot sent from the future
can be for gay marriage because his
daughter is then
really it's the least you can ask for
somebody
it actually the least you can add so is
this just proves that the number one
thing the gay people can do is come out
because look it happen with Dick Cheney
when his daughter came out he came
around this guy's daughter came out we
had that there was a problem order I
think
senator his and Sun came out sir so it's
basically like if you come out you can
pretty much affect the the convictions a
collocation but I am
there a positive way of thinking about
it yeah ended up being like actually be
gracious which now we will
yes we should be gracious what should we
just accept that should the gay
community just accept all these people
no matter what they've done in their
passion in the second you change
should you be as exonerated about what a
bitch really marching in the Pride
Parade
but we can like weekend you hate him
what we can is except that he evolved on
the issue
without making him like a you know a gay
icon yeah and if you want to be gay icon
but I think maybe not make them would
have to morph into an old lady probably
she wear away me I Yap but I think now
now arm do you think it matters even if
he's not doing is necessary because his
daughter but just for
selling a book cuz I think that's also
part a bit like how do you sell your
book lie with the property lawyer report
against
gay marriage and now i'm for it but saw
a book you know I care
from now on it but you may even take
that be right back I
I think whatever gets people on the
right side of this issue is a good thing
I don't think that makes them
great people cuz I don't think this
issue makes being
for gay marriage in saying that people
who love each other should be able to
get married
doesn't make you a good person that's
just what as people
we should expect to beat other you know
one extra credit yeah
well I mean I would love some extra
credit has given extra credit is what
time are you
yeah totally for being at the apt an
ally for being an ally
you know i i do what I can the I
up does anyone about the other way %uh
that it doesn't make anything is there
anyone
thats pro-gay marriage that certainly
have we heard that at all
it may be that way through but I went to
Berkeley which is a very liberal school
the largest by campus actually they
called republicans because
people come world moderate and they're
so freaked out by liberalism that they
like backtrack and
I'm these really conservative like
asshole so I feel like
that could happen let me get so scared
about like it
marriage equality I mean I just a minute
like double down to become like super
anti after thinking it was okay
yeah is not a little bit like the
chick-fil-a theory like the more you
for the more the gates bought cheaply
the more chicken they sold like a little
better that
or the more that they bought duck
dynasty said only the ratings were cute
now I guess there
all Great Hall Paula Dean still people
rally behind polity every time she's a
subject of our race is that what
happened I think there may be a little
different good for her brand
yeah knob no I I think with people will
begin to devolve on this issue
to devolve on this issue when a gay
divorce
still hurts yes started popping up
you'll see a lot of gay people who will
be like
you know like I don't know who's right
for me you know gay marriage in phiri is
great but
yeah I want to go back to the sink or I
do you have a friend right now that a
lesbian in the middle in the works and I
feel like it's very that's very edging
what do you think that a live in a horse
first though
you know they're headed toward letter
endorsing a very first two they got very
first a divorce for ca$h
there's some you are jokers but I i've
walked up to the edge into a turnaround
got were
we thank the good allies like to make
that joke I
I let's move our talk about when the low
and you know she had this show on
own which is Oprah's network that nobody
knows what channel its on except for
Oprah
apparently and the show got cancelled
needed one season it just got camp that
had poor rating surprise surprise
and there's a lot of drama around the
show now I actually hadn't watched
the show until we decide to do things
like caught up a little bit question
your
book clip about Lindsay show I may have
additions to certain things life but I'm
not essentially your typical
panicked it's not going and what not
confers
I know the difference in my long and
stupid idiotic and you know it's going
bad like to know that was raised well
whatever its but
and its unit
the
but there's certain things that people
don't know what around people sometimes
but I see that now
you the we don't usually do this kinda
stuff on the show but I thought this was
particularly interesting because it's
related to Oprah and
how much truth there we get mad at her
and lindsey is just that a trainer
so first just well let's just talk about
the train wreck part of it
I am why are we obsessed with train
wrecks why
wide no matter with Justin Bieber peas
in a slut bucket you know the bill
clinton
and you know amanda Bynes towards buying
at a window was my bond which is that
was the upsetting part
it's like why worry it s these people
what you see celebrities climb very high
and you let him fall I'm inspired the
kind of story we've been conditioned to
expect
and so when someone is that they miss
and that popular and that a rich you
kind of expect this
thus downfall aspect to happen that's
like that with the story ends
yeah from I think that's been around for
so long we've seen ups and downs
down I personally watched the show
hoping you would be
I mean I'm all those people actually
want her to exceed so used to like that
somehow she was gonna be.
get her Mayakoba through this well I
don't know what I thought
but I kept watching so Eimear its
its top I mean she really is actually
she's trying to push is also very
diluted and so you can see that in the
show
yeah um now what channel is it by the
way I had no idea you don't even know
Nuby
I DVR'd I don't yeah I don't know
already the DVR now's
yeah what it what do you think what's
the train wreck explanation because
there's something deep
in the human psyche that love why I
think part of it is actually in
just did addiction to narrative and the
fact that when someone reaches the top
thats if it was a movie that be the end
of the narrative
but in life it continues to go on so we
seek out
the next part of the story we want to
see the next part of the story
and I think this is a
you know kind of a the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle it's like
something that is watched will be
changed
and when you start pointing a camera and
during paparazzi around
these people at all times like
that will drive someone crazy and I
think we've seen that with so many
people now it's
it I mean TMZ I have plays this
triste whenever somebody gets into
serious trouble and something really bad
happens
teams he certainly seems like really
like and respect for out rather like
Syrian really are praying for in
thinking you were a big part of what
happened here this is a
someone who maybe didn't like shoot
someone but provided the gun
their I know he's evolved step over hope
they are you personally affected their
views of something like to put some that
powder alcohol in now with
happy with the help of them from TMZ
yeah 11 Mar Harvey Levin put it in his
little young sucking on that being
constantly
amid this remind me a little bit that
South Park
episode with you know that humans we
step human sacrifice and now
we're not sacrificing these people to
death but we're we're just putting them
up there that I get that sorta goes
to what you're saying about it there's
like this deep needed this is really
dark
zeiger yet not as dark as the show
Lindsay the papers I feel darker than
let you set up to the part that may be
really want to talk about this though
with the Oprah connection because you're
everything Oprah is built herself on has
been actually what we think OVR the
reverse
Lindsay Lohan and everyone was like oh
she's gonna give her a chance and Oprah
configuring the Linkin up because oprah
can do anything but
even Oprah now the chief a lot better
than
I don't about makes me very sad the
whole show I'm still reeling
yeah it's been a it's been a it up
several weeks but I'll I i think that
I don't know it's hard because with hope
for you you kind of wonder she come into
this with the intentions you know what
she
actually trying to help someone that is
that is her per thing
so we believe that's your thing but she
also wants to make money right you want
somebody to watch the charity our
network so I think it's a mix look up
for
official out how to pay reprogramming is
doing pretty well do we have a laugh
track and someone put it in your lawn
tractor ever put on your show here
you're laughing but it's doing really
well yeah I'll mmm
people love people love Tyler Perry I'll
in the not so much but I i think that
its accommodation one in the ratings
also believing that I think she budget
crap a story where
it is this addict who has failed so many
times before but now she suddenly
it's a come to Jesus moment and Oprah is
Jesus and that's like that so that's the
show but that was isn't happening has
landed on the predictable and you can't
kinda
force in attic into that that narrative
yeah
so that's the part that I think if you
think this is if that's the case let's
people over all the credit what she
really did issue a helpful in the
you know all that well then she sorta
failed in her mission right
sure I i mean ship ok
anything what she did 13 with Gemma
Sardar
she was a James fry and she let him know
that a
but I RI I think the problem is also
lindsey's you know who knows what her
addiction and her real
situation is but there seems to be a
component that we're fame
is enabling the worst aspects over
addictions
add well I watched some love the show
and its
seem to me that this was not
a that the way if you really wanted to
help when the low and the way to help
her was not to put her exact line
like to take what's been driving her
crazy and then just
blow it out times a million it would be
to
remove her from the spotlight and right
isn't that something that sort of
perverse I mean Oprah must have thought
about your gonna take like a
famous addicted person right i just
bided it some other things too which is
sorta said she was or wasn't wasn't
really pair that
and that you're gonna give them more of
that league isn't that a little
just about devils advocate there is an
avid accountability to it
and I think that I want your house wives
tale Hurley health
them camera with Adam India yeah I don't
want to tell a pair not right now I
don't
edges and I know that exist um Kim
Richards recovering alcoholic
said the show basically saved her life
because she was being filmed all the
time
she could secretly drink she couldn't
avoid people call your alcoholic on
camera
yeah and made her get treatment and
that's the normal course of action for
an addict I'm just saying
there is rather it is an aspect
accountability when you're telling
someone
Bravo an hour truly the greatest man
alive I'll be attics
yes strike on Bravo added to that list
what are you doing whatever sorry all
gone
yeah 'em what do you guys do how do you
personally deal with the train wreck
people cuz like amanda Bynes when she
was going off the rails and and beer and
all that like
I follow them on Twitter just really
purely for the jokes
but every now and again I do start like
when amanda Bynes was really
going down the tubes started feeling bad
I was like I'm not gonna joke about any
workers
she literally could you show up in a
gutter and then I'll I guess I'll feel
better how do you
could you want to be part is I guys
right we're all in it and
I I think there's a difference between
someone like Justin Bieber who I know it
doesn't seem
like there's an addiction and it doesn't
seem like there's it seems like he's
kinda vay
smart ass kid and he does
asshole things run a grand scale at
eight oh yeah i mean he he with his
basically Dennis the Menace with like a
lot of money and accountability yeah
where is Lindsay Lohan and and amanda
Bynes there seems to be some
some actual medical mental but possibly
a issues at play and that
there's a difference between it feels
darker and
meaner and it's the same way when people
joke about you know like Miley Cyrus is
in the hospital recently for like a real
like shit bad
reaction to penicillin or something a by
the the jokes immediately about
you know I'll what may be the best team
teaser
Road she's pregnant with so and so does
into and it just becomes
you know but if something truly terrible
happens to those pursuing
so happy how do you know if the ref I
mean there's you have to cut back a lot
things and you know it's like how much
of a dick is that person
but I'll with Justin Bieber like he is a
he is a day like that we don't feel
guilty for making
I love him right I'm with someone who's
cooley struggling and you have to look
at it and say like
can I make a joke and limit myself after
doing so and I think bed
I hold back a lot of people because I'd
don't back it kinda help with that
very calm and then everyone smother
someone like Bieber is a great example
who just
I mean where there's no sympathy for him
like we're not worried about him
if he were clearly struggling maybe I
would step back but right now he's just
be in just 10 he is just the rich can
that spoiled rich kid
is a is this is a problem but it's not
like gasoline you can
you can treat medically cell are more
integrated
yeah yeah but it would help to fix him
give it to him but I don't think it's
gonna happen
yeah very well said beaver you're
welcome to come on the show a time and
defend yourself
we'd love to have you okay I a lot of
people think congress doesn't do much of
anything I am one of those people but
they're working hard for you
you know they just did they introduced a
bill I to
cut down on photoshopping I've models
in magazines yeah this is your
government working for you
it is called the truth in advertising
act and %uh let's get a excerpt from the
bill
an increasing amount academic evidence
links exposure to such
altered images with emotional mental and
physical health issues
including eating disorders especially
among children and teenagers
there's a particular concern about the
marketing such images
to children and teenagers a
and of course you know we see this all
the time I magazine that lately there's
been a trend
celebrities that release the actual
pictures of themselves
I think Lena Dunham is already started
this we've got some photoshop images
up celebrities in case you're not sure
of what's going on these magazines were
fatal
to it is with you and we just talked
about when the that Lindy to the left
and that is her airbrushed itself to the
right
I mean without being too glib about the
thing that we just did before that she
doesn't look back you mean either one of
them but you can see clearly like to
create a lot of the latter alien this
going on
on that that picture to the right in its
you know clearly photoshopped and
cleaned up in all that arise look alien
ish
George Clooney they took some wrinkles
out and here
little more little more color guys feel
free to chat and where the well
after way where like before they like or
looks great it after looks awful
enough money they took the salt pepper
how you're going to like that but
growing
grab some changes adams apple to make a
more manly however lightly dark are a
jerk it has eyebrows to
its which is a would have usually Peter
Gallagher good idea
but let you are there some artist
somewhere going we better dark in his
adams apple meaning literally said we
need more contrary right hinge adams
apple
what is name would not be happy about
that who got the Adams Apple removed
percent Bruce Jenner without the added
that one more period
and we got the best possible picture we
could find a Katy Perry and their
yeah I mean look at to the left you see
a somewhat human course with some pores
and
that she and and then they what is this
obsession
we make every look like aliens it's very
porcelain doll
yet but i wanna see someone who looks
like they've never actually been in the
Sun
ever yeah I made and they sleep in with
your eyes are having a look at that
anyway let's go back later
yeah I think it's a great bill actually
having it's a really good the problem is
a
my distrust of congress means that like
way if it ever gets past
it will be toothless and nothing will
happen and you know
but then again cigarette companies can
advertise in all budget places these be
able advertise
yeah although sadly we have electronic
cigarette advertisements all over the
place that sure the time
yeah they can't take that away today and
I don't share Yahoo I think the building
a far enough
really I think we should go to the
people I where aa
I wanna see like put more flaws in two
people got make us feel better about
ourselves out
Jack Swagger yeah I would be nice really
just like
ruin them yeah I don't mean to be mean
and a saying like I wanna see
Katy Perry with like a big guy at and
bad skin and like
you know that having a horrible hair day
I wanna see that not only get started on
makeup I wanted them to actually create
that image
so what is the for the people that read
these magazines and look at people there
there are already more beautiful than
them or richer than them and have all
the things that they don't have
and then on top of that they make them
look even better than they look normally
what was going on like psychologically
what do you think you're going all
I mean it it's creating the something to
aspire to
but is fictional me rather than it does
not exist in the universe yeah
and so well you're right because they're
starting to look like a jerk but you're
starting to create a situation where
its literally unattainable like these
goals are unattainable
and that causes perpetual
and completely complete failure it's
always going to be tell you there's no
way to reach that's enough
and it cause of all mental health issues
in eating disorders an awful things I
there's no reason why we need
Kate Upton to be my eye heard
a from a friend of a friend to was
working on that movie with Kate Upton
that they were he they were doing
digital Baxter make her look
like slightly skinnier in the movie it's
okay to be gorgeous were you talking
about
Graham why do we need skinny like
nobody's like
other thing I know about Kate Upton is
how tiny she is yeah
and it's insane well I think there was
something where promo shot even have Hot
in Cleveland where they even
try to make very white look a little
slimmer and it's real you
but I really like sex her up because you
really have to sack the right trying to
master the body white yeah away from
here is a small group of people
and her that do that I am but are we all
doing this in our own life too because
we all have that Instagram thing and we
can blur things and we can make
ourselves look Tanner
and all that so that is is that even
more perverse that regular people
I don't think so what's really minor the
weather let's look their best I don't
think they were actually lets you like
actually bought a bigger Instagram's
which is a pain he paid a lot to do that
from
I mean you know I had a friend who was
doing that secretly when I found out
it was one of the reasons I kinda mad I
I was like this is
such a karate I was like this person is
such a broad your photoshopping your own
it i cant the but yes like online dating
see this said we're always a claim their
best selves and like her
perhaps a an altered way report
everything and also how to do what
celebrity magazines yet around that
seems normal to me that's kinda just
human nature versus like actually
the story from us for what they look
like nothing like themselves
and how this like perfect for me to
think this in in the world
by the way we have a tremendous amount
battling on the lens here so greatly
that there is pretty damn one rate right
now
yeah put tear tear point when you
started this whole thing about congress
is there any chance congress like what
discourage have anything to do with this
like isn't a bad thing
complicate do anything they have like a
six percent approval rating they
literally can't pass a lot this point
nobody likes them
and this is what they're doing is that
store to the state America
summed up in a national yes and no I
actually this is what are the issues
what I'm sorry Mike well somebody's
trying to do something that has actual
impact well this I feel like a law like
this
actually as much more impact on regular
America could have much more positive
impact on america
that a lot of work around the assets
that their job that that I have no faith
in them to
get anything done on this issue you have
its they're the worst
they're just or any final but that
congress I yeah I mean I don't think
they have any control over magazine
today I mean I know how this works out
there making a four-set
yeah I mean most likely they're just
gonna set industry guidelines right that
won't
that no no he raped many for change
great so good luck with your
industry guidelines people were aware
okay I
this was fascinating so according to the
LA times the number up californians
aged 5264 who live in their parents
homes
has surged in recent years people 50
264 moving back in every other is just
the Millennials moving back in with mom
and dad know
its people in middle to upper middle-age
we've got more info Korea
for seven years through 2012 the number
of Californians age 50 to 64 who live in
their parents homes what
sixty 7 percent to about a hundred
ninety-four
house in seems in Thane among 18- to
24-year-olds 1.6 million californians
have moved in with their parents though
that a 33 percent jump in 2006 the pace
is still have that
a B-fifty 264 age group
a and there there's so much here
I dunno about her in that age group yet
I am at work where
you looking great lottery Lloyd riser
but mister
18 is this really an economic thing do
you think that that really is what's
going on here that these people just are
fallen on hard economic times it seems
weird for that age group is in it
yeah it does but I feel like um the
first I hope this means that we can't
stop reading money I'll try n pieces
them is not as the Millennials like
that's recent trend pieces about 15
64-year-old that was one of the first
things railroading of their parents yeah
wet days a jerk with a nice when you saw
this because it was like oh they're not
just
da and how you know millennial DS
euro-area
so isn't it refreshing yes indeed some
other age group B besmirch
me with a boomers yeah it's sad it's sad
because like you know of their economic
issues a play and I'm it's more
stigmatized back home when you're fifty
then when you are
20 but um yeah I'll say it is it is kind
of like when the things we look for her
trends like
these lazy Millennials I feel like these
issues kinda far the economy at large
not just like
a Gerber ager a people being you know
lazy not working right so we the bad
economy altogether people just attacked
the Millennials because they're the ones
getting in the workforce in a bad
economy not the legs were so obnoxious
and it's like were easy targets
things we don't feel well sell my
goodness arm
should she will be judging these you
know look in your honor
you know been you're looking really
almost everyone lived with their mother
in here
8 should we be more like Italy I think
that I think we should be more like
Italy
mile away Stanford yeah I leave know
it's
I think it's add more than anything and
I think it's a statement on the economy
in a huge way but I think it's also seen
on the table jobs that are available and
a lot of people in this age group are
trained for jobs that no longer exist
and aren't properly train for the jobs
that are starting to exist
I'm I am and the stupid 50 is
not you know that middle-aged and
there's not a a great way to train
up tired of middle-aged people to learn
the
you know you want to you I do job
training you want to
give people a chance to get educated
enough to get back into the workforce
but
move so quickly that by the time you
know somebody is trying to computers
in the nineties is already if they have
been staying up with that is already
totally behind I'll route now yeah so
it's not just a bad economy with them
they're not
train properly for the for the job that
exist right that we put too much a
premium
I'm getting at the house like even this
reminds me like every episode of The
Cosby Show
right clip was always trying to get
those Leo now
out that al well yeah we do know
culturally you know you're right though
in Europe it's all the same in many
other countries is not the same in the
US
has a weird thing about kids going to
college and never coming back
which is not realistic in this economy
so I think that um
yet so we're cultural thing I don't know
with other cultures
are so into people who have been out of
the house for thirty years
then coming back rack but some yeah I'm
you to see Michael
a weird thing we've had been conditioned
to believe that you have to kind of get
out immediately and never look back
yeah well it also makes sense the what
started this terrible
economy a was all that surgery done but
with started
the economy was the housing crisis and
so
a lot of the people in the 50 to 64
Adrian probably
owned houses that were foreclosed upon
and so they were probably former
homeowners who are now renters who can
afford the rent any word like
if the natural conclusion I love people
who were foreclosed on
eight years ago yeah I mean there's
definitely let me a reason that's gone
is there something nice actually about
people this aid moving back in you know
your elderly parents at a rally in the
80's or 90's at this point
and you know people do it's usually
thought of the other way that the
elderly parent moves in with the
a child or they kick them off to Shady
Pines I so does get one dollar goes
right they appreciate it I am
so but is there something nice about
this that we should actually respect
more you know I can japan really really
have a respect for the elderly
that we sorted don't have here he's a
bum me out about the LA Times piece
um the woman in the P says that it was
because we're twins that you back and if
they had not been around should have
lived in a car
so I was like a small reading this
because my mom read that I'd rather live
in my car that with my mom
think should be a little upset yeah I
will we link to the article in The
description by the ways you can find out
about a bit more about her yeah it's
just depressing it's so sad and it is
nice
to be with family and to be but nobody
wants to come back at hand
the also nobody wants to be written up
in the LA Times about how they came back
at it
well here already embarrassing enough
but to go to
be like yeah so than my live really fell
apart and I have to live with my parents
%uh my kids like that sucks I think a
really read about yeah
well from getting older in a bad economy
a robot
taking your job yeah that's right you
know last week we did a story on
this study about how in 2060 basically
because
have an aging population it's going to
stay alive people living with kids that
are all economic system can be click
Apply governable
a class war between all people and young
people read Albert Brooks 2030 if you
have been
now futurologists are saying
the there well they're basically making
bold predictions about what's gonna
happen in 2040
to the workforce this is from expat jobs
dot com
let's take a look for here are some
other things that they predict will be
happening
by 2040 this is not that long now we may
be requesting biotic implants for our
and that will make us able to perform
tasks
as fast as any machine plastic surgeons
will be able to operate additional brain
processing power
I can use that at the current 30 7.4
hour work week will increase
third 250 and a half hours and we will
have left
sex in a lifetime as a result a reduced
human interaction I think so many things
are already
happening up a little so let's look at
what the worker will look like in 2014
workers will have red eyes from working
all hours
also maybe from being the Terminator
weaker eyes from close-up wearable
devices much like Google after we talk a
lot about
a smaller penis as a result in fewer
sexual partners over a lifetime
as human interaction reduces I didn't
know that your penis growth in to
YouTube
damage that you're having a bigger brain
with software in memory update
in which people will think Rd in our era
get implanted here where to eliminate
cumbersome Bluetooth headsets and
smartphones
and smart fingers with chips that aid
work
okay so I paid the puter 40/20/40 you're
not buying this is such not suck
we're gonna look back at this segment
yeah I have a path dikes I have jobs
that come on
I'm calling shenanigans yeah we're gonna
look back at this segment the same way
we look back a popular Mechanics reviews
from the 40 S
you know I series will fly high above us
like no it's this that won't happen the
idea
that technology can reduce sexual
interaction is crazy if anything we've
seen the exact opposite to be true
right Google glass is not gaining a
foothold anything people are rejecting
the weirdness love it a I think being
conditioned by years and years and years
above dystopian future movies and novels
has made us very suspicious of the
computers that operators tell me every
week every much way too many sci-fi
yeah we're not but we're not going to be
like oh we can have a droid that can do
our jobs
yeah I'd like to hire that droid I
reaction smoke we watch Total Recall
every night before I go to know that you
showed you
yeah because that's just a good lecture
us but a
this is just it I mean it's fun to think
about
but it's also crazy okay I'm gonna play
back a little bit on that but I'll let
you go first I give Jack although I do
wanna be
I do wanna that person is like TV's a
fat but i wanna sit back and other way I
believe he's
these guys and believe us we were
totally right you want to be that guy
I want to be the guy is wrong but I
don't know I think I it's all its its
complete bullshit but
I do think this expert actually true I
disagree a jack on that I think that
our we have reduced me interaction and
that the movie her was like very
true to life or will be brain sometime
we'll we will be able to kind of find
connectivity in and server sexual
release outside have
human partners right well already I mean
I don't you know this but there's porn
on the internet
heard back yeah I haven't haven't seen
any but I've heard that that's the thing
yeah I would argue that the last twenty
years have
lead to much more promiscuous lay I feel
like
suicides much more promiscuous now than
it was in the nineteen fifties
right and a big part of that is because
we're watching a lot of porn and
were people are getting married much
later in life you know it's
it the number I've twenty-somethings I
know myself included were like
oh I'm not doing anything about getting
married on 30 you like
the would never that would been crazy
talk in nineteen 1950
and you know the rise of tender and
grinder and its these things are made so
people can we get the right up together
looking over the
right you know rate this player a very
long but yes you can do and I don't
think I don't think anybody's been like
you know porns been so great I'm just
done with sex life
I know I think anything is the opposite
right affect were made
I don't know the I don't even have a sex
robot over having to deal with a human
being
i feel like im I cover the sect retired
a lot about the sector about their
coming to
no pun intended I their I'm a I
I think I think you're ahead mister I
think you can tell right there about
people
the Don Draper's worried about how to
pitch the section with the exact so
okay I'll so I to me it seems like a lot
of this stuff is actually possible
because it only 20 something years in
the future and if you think about what
what we were like twenty years ago we
didn't know about or thereabout we were
connected to the Internet all-time
we wouldn't even be able to believe all
the stuff we could do now so that's why
I look at this list
and yet maybe our eyes will be turning
red but like the recipe
seems Cucina yeah like we can't nobody
can predict
what what you know there's that famous
quote from the Microsoft guy in like
nineteen
81 is like know where the future will
ever anyone ever need more than four
megabytes of data you know bike I feel
like that's why I kinda buy into this
stuff on my crazy futurist
you're insane I think that no i i get
that I think that
but at the same time with things that
have happened we've become
accent like exactly now but the things
that happen in the car also kinda in
line with what we
expected to some degree like video calls
I mean
what is actually happening at that
outside of what we could've imagined
right what we thought the video calls
can be on this big machine and it ended
up in our in our hands right but no I
mean that
yeah I these things happen bound to
happen in such a extreme ways only by
2040 were to see a drastically different
I mean there might be a nuclear war that
I pull out before that but there
if we arrive story this week we're gonna
head if we survive I don't leave me that
drastically different
some anything's happening kinda
gradually as they're happening is it
feels that way so I don't think it's
going to be so way to wake up suddenly
with
I'm robots working our jobs yeah I also
think technology is made us more
connected than maybe I'm buying
what Mark Zuckerberg itself but I do
think technology is made is more
connected than we've ever been
I have met I'm at both the view on the
internet that I
through Twitter and threw it had nothing
to do with that yeah no
yeah well as a router perks Traci when I
mean I
like this is a human interactions
occurring that would have occurred
this is being broadcast on your like its
the
were becoming what I don't think human
interaction is is lessening
and I don't think that anybody is
thinking that
poet only I could just talk to smarter
child
are or what it was either like clever
bot or one of those instead of being a
twitter-like interacting with actual
people
a I i think we may have less face to
face contact
at some point but I think there will
always be a need for face to face
contact
and I think even video calls
where about face to face contact like
it's and even that's not really take I
mean skype is a big part of meetings and
big
but the idea I've like talking to your
friend in the same city on a video call
I still feel like it's like not the most
common thing Respir what
you know some TV shows because the
clever it's a easy way to get people the
same room
like I I don't think that's like really
taken off in a huge why I think
in point in 2040 things are gonna look a
lot like they will now only with maybe
like smaller phones
and hope for your water cars frequently
giant retro phone all this act more
yeah going out there alright well Jackie
given it a very pleasant
ending here II Jack Moore with
tightening their twitter is our right
down below
and you guys need to really like and
share and what are some other buzzword
buttons give me something I meant
comment I engage engage
highly in what we're doing here because
that's when January now and then one day
maybe we'll meet in person
and the soggy view alright thanks for
watching with the injury